many more people should be leaving their  jobs a lot of people like oh I've been  at the shop for seven years if I leave  now I've given it all up I'm wasting  time I'm wasting everything you're not  wasting it staying in a cancer-filled  environment is wasting time when it's a  dead end it's a dead end  you staying longer doesn't change it  being a dead end  you leaving and starting over with the  experiences and things you've learned is  being on the offense not giving up so  many people are in these abusive  business relationships where they don't  want to leave because they think they've  given up all the time they've put in  that's like abusive that's the framework  of the abusive nature of it you need to  [ __ ] leave that was one [ __ ] word  to your question